let's talk let's talk sitcoms cuz I've
got two sitcom stars here and people
seem to think that the day of the sitcom
may be coming to a close reality TV is
mocking everything up but you guys are
both on great shows and as I just said
you're you just shot a pilot for what I
think is going to be another huge show
in girls world do you think that the
sitcom will always be here to stay even
though the television landscape is
changing
i I do I do I think as long as there's
they're smart intelligent writers out
there i I think there will always be a
place for it and I think that there's a
special place in everyone's heart for it
I think if there's a lot of comfort in
it yeah I think reality TV is really I
mean I'm guilty of watching it I think
it's a great way to numb out but I think
that there's something when you want to
actually laugh and and bring a gift to
your soul then you'll tune in to
something with a soul so you're saying
I'm saying that as someone who actually
does numb out with reality TV but
sometimes you you don't want an amount
you want to pleasure your living from
the three camera traditional sitcom
thing that everyone loves and I agree it
is like this comforting thing that
reality TV doesn't give you comfort
so is it particularly guilt full when
you're watching it but you know I like
when I watch something and you start
laughing out loud you don't even intend
to you're just watching it and then you
get this big laugh you know it's really
it is it just releases you laughter
releases you from the stress that is
surely there every day yeah it's there
every day I mean this following it is
stressful so I think both of your
stories are kinda interesting because
you jumped in on Big Bang with the great
ensemble cast and you jumped in when the
show was a couple seasons in and you
became the breakout star of a show that
was an ensemble cast but you became
bigger than the star that was supposed
to be the big star so we'll get to that
but what was it like jumping in on
something that was that was huge already
but since you joined really has become
like huge huge huge was a three it may
have been caught on a second
big bang didn't catch on the first
season cuz I watched what season did you
job in it I came into the third season
it was I mean it was a dream come true
it was supposed to be a one-time thing
as everybody wanted that job I remember
how'd she get that job I was it was I
was a little excited so excited and I
was a fan of the show before I joined
the cast so coming in just for that one
episode I was supposed to do I was over
the moon excited and that cast is
amazing they're all just such a great
group of people and so it's been just a
dream come true yeah was it tough though
to jump in on something that was
although it wasn't as huge as it is now
that was successful obviously and and
now I mean it really it's the number one
comedy in the country and you know your
face is every on every subway I know
you've beaten two and a half minutes
it's it's very surreal it's very I mean
I'm super grateful for it I think you
know the cast was so welcoming I think
the writers did a fantastic job of
making it a very organic transition so
it wasn't just like we're bringing on
new characters we're shoving it in your
face yeah and I'm very grateful to them
for that because I think that you know
whenever you're bringing in new
characters to a nerdy established
already successful entity it could be
you know yeah but I think they did it
the architects behind the show and our
producers and our writers I think people
get resentful yeah yeah yeah
unfortunately well you kind of had the
reverse thing because 2 to 7 was an
established success show but you were by
far the breakout star I mean everybody
knew Sandra Mary and could recite every
one ear Alliance was that how did that
feel to you how was it like working with
everybody and difficult this agent at
this time and all it still goes on it
really does it doesn't get you think it
would lessen it doesn't but I tell it's
heavy is the head that wears the crown
I'll wear the Dern crown that's what I
say yeah because if you're gonna be
funny or not I mean it takes courage to
be successful so when you get it like
she came to did the job you did one show
which I love hearing because that's what
I did I was only supposed to do seven
shows yeah and they wrote it in like you
said so but also for
that's why this one all out that's only
seven shows but I got to lose give me
another job that's the way you feel she
probably did that I'm gonna do my best
so you can connect you know you connect
the dots I call it you know but it's not
easy being successful you know sometimes
it's like do you think you and when you
chop to a dishes or somewhere somebody's
gig they got I'm here you know yeah you
really so I push that back when I'm off
now I used to be all of that very
braggadocio up but I let that go cuz
it's just too much work all right well
I'm gonna humble you both right now
because I know every actor says oh I
can't watch myself I can't watch myself
so you know what we're gonna do we're
gonna make you both watch yourself let's
go to the videotape we're very different
people Howard so communication is a
little tricky all right so that's
melissa rauch is better in person thank
you
how do you feel when you watch it
because everyone says that thing about
oh I don't like watching myself but yet
we're public figures so it's like I feel
like people don't understand why it's
tough I don't know yeah I don't know a
little self critic yeah yeah even now
she was that looking to see you know
mm-hmm we could have done something else
you know and it was funny but you always
think I could have done something else
yeah so when you're watching that you're
thinking oh is it a visual thing or it's
about the app thing it's interesting
everything I mean even if you have you
ever left a voicemail for someone and
they didn't hear it back you know like I
don't sound like that it's I mean
granted I'm putting on voices and things
like that but it's it's that except it's
everything it's like listening to a
voice mail while looking in the mirror
is very deep oh you know let's get deep
let's show miss Jackie O do something
you must have an order for you I mean
of the world we just talked to Jack hey
Harry great break homes who says it was
lovely it was a comedian as well he was
a you know he's manic depressive did you
know that manic-depressive yeah yeah
undiagnosed let's focus on Jack hey
there how do you feel when you're now
that's 20 years ago or so or 15 years
whatever it is so you have a little time
Melissa that was probably about a year
ago how do you feel when you look back
on something like that I'm glad that I
didn't know cuz if I had known I might
have tailored it or tapered it down I
had no I was just going for the little
funny and just you know the the rapidity
of the moment you know but now you know
I can do stuff so quickly and I can tell
you can't do you pick it out you can too
you have to you have to be like this you
have to quit so I don't judge as much
you know I kind of just make sure that
it looks good and not stupid you know
what I mean but I don't mind though
still be humid oh I don't mind slapstick
all of that yeah I don't mind roll I can
tell you I don't mind rolling around the
ground to get a laugh you know did you
see those guys on MTV by the way with
their pants on Seth Rogen and MTV you
know those awards they give up those
silly eyes anyway speaking of putting
your pants on anyway I'm sorry I digress
bonobos calms the official outfitter of
the Reuben report enter code TRR to zero
for 20% off your first purchase